foreign
people keep sending me these videos to
rile me up and the new trend now on Tick
Tock is the 40-year mortgage and so let
me explain what This is 40 years 40-year
mortgage so you know about the 15 you
love the 30 but let me introduce you to
the 40-year mortgage it reminds me of
the office with uh Dwight and Michael
where he says a 30-year mortgage at
Michael's age essentially means that
he's buying a coffin now if I were to
buy my coffin I'd get one with thicker
walls
a great quote so here's what's actually
happening John the 40-year mortgage is
not a thing you can even go do which I'm
really glad I'm gonna beg to differ
because I saw it on Instagram so George
is wrong so this became a trend and
became a big Google search really what
this is is it's for folks who are
already already had an FHA mortgage and
they're on the brink of foreclosure and
so this is a loan modification that they
can now use in order to avoid a short
sale or foreclosure this is an official
Kick the Can it's for people who are so
broke they're on the verb to bankruptcy
and they said maybe in 10 years your
situation will improve yes and so My
worry is mortgage companies go oh we can
make more money off of this we should
offer it to normal people or some guy
like me walks in is like hey I I want to
only pay this much for my monthly
payment how far can we go and they're
like yeah sure let's do it on the 10
years so the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau cfpb as we call it in
the biz I saw that tattoo in your arm
yeah I put I'm a big fan so they
actually it's not a qualified mortgage
for them they have set the rules for
this and it's not a qualified mortgage
because this is what led to the Great
Recession in 2007 to nine subprime
mortgages people who couldn't afford
houses went well if we do the 40-year we
can barely afford it that's great and
all of a sudden the banks gave all these
people mortgages who shouldn't have got
them and it created the bubble and it
popped so all that to say John this is a
nightmare and if you didn't believe me
can I just share the numbers with you of
course so this article has a
hypothetical loan a 440 000 home with 13
down
so you have a loan for three hundred
eighty three thousand dollars on a
15-year fixed rate about six percent
right now you would have paid about 581
thousand dollars total cost so that I
mean that sucks that's still a lot you
paid an interest but when you move to
the 30-year mortgage you will have paid
eight hundred and fifty thousand dollars
on that 383 cost
on the 40-year mortgage on drum roll
please
you would have paid over a million
dollars
for that loan that you took out for
three hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars so the the
it almost tripled this will become a
product because the bank there's too
much money to be made did you I mean
look at these numbers America I'd like
to they made almost 700 Grand on a loan
for 383. well yeah but they're gonna be
40 years to collect on it well you're
buying a coffin they don't seem too
concerned they're playing the long game
John listen we have to get to a place
where we are no longer
fighting scratching for a wiggle room
well and we're scratching for lower
payments John because we need
flexibility because inflation and what
if I want more to my life than wiggle
room and flexibility and okay I can
afford that payment and that payment and
that payment when I look at my total
take home for the month
I I wanna unhook from The Matrix
completely I want to solve for Freedom
here I want to get off this whole ride I
get off the whole ride
I don't think most people just walking
through the day realize this weight
that's on their chest and they think
that this is as deep as I can breathe
and they think this is as good as my
sleep is ever going to be and they think
that just a couple more beers and this
is as good as it gets and there's just
so much more to life and this just feels
like
someone who's can't breathe and it's
like I'll give you a little sip of air
through a straw every day for 10 more
years and we're gonna high-five you and
call that life I don't want that life
the key to a great life is not lower
payments it's no payments no payments
that's true margin that's free to
Freedom choose Freedom every single time
stop selling your soul for wiggle room
choose free